I don't know I feel like our family
bullied each other enough where we know
we're not dead
no we're not what tons any of us would
call us like the girls I'm just being
logical girls hold themselves to so much
of a higher standard of my guys let's be
realistic you're not a 10 we know this
like I'm just kidding I wouldn't get as
much flag for the man look if I was
attacked
I just got too much of it I'm just like
if I was a 10 I would have been like
asked to homecoming high school I'm I'm
realistic yeah it's like if I was a 10
it's like oh my gosh it's like even the
manosphere guys I'm like I'm on your
side and they're calling me I'm just
saying if you're a 10 it doesn't matter
what your personality is somebody will
ask you out at some point like